check out this week's must-see movies  dearest Tom when I first saw you I felt  like I knew you the light between oceans  is a heartbreaking drama about a couple  torn between the child they love and the  truth we have to tell people it's a  lover hello dr. Shapiro in the sci-fi  horror thriller Morgan a risk-management  Pro investigates an incident involving a  dangerous bioengineered girl don't  breathe a blood pumping thriller from  the creators of Evil Dead now you're  gonna see what I see let's check out  this week's fantasy patient so what's  your weekend ticket going to be let us  know in the comments below we'll see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]